à
[Applaudissements]
je suis engagé avec montpellier pour 40
millions d'algériens
sans les droits des femmes il n'y aura
pas de démocratie
l'égalité c'est aussi une inspiration
c'est pas seulement une revendication
on veut une algérie tous les algériens
dans leur diversité
on a géré jeunes forte qui est ouverte
aussi sur le monde moi tout ça me parle
et il fallait une révolution pour
meubles pour que ça puisse se faire
elle a 34 ans elle fait partie de cette
nouvelle génération de jeunes
majoritaire en algérie celle qui a
obtenu le départ du président et qu'ils
continuent de manifester
parmi ces revendications celle de
l'égalité hommes femmes
[Musique]
si on comprend bien ce que ça veut dire
un état de droit est ce que veut dire
démocratie c'est tout à fait normal et
naturel de revendiquer l'égalité ne peut
pas y avoir de la démocratie sans
égalité
amel zen étaient déjà connus des jeunes
algériens
elle l'est encore plus depuis qu'elle a
créé avec d'autres artistes
cette chanson il est devenu une sorte
des meneurs de la contestation actuelle
très fier et fait aimer eux aussi parce
que c'est une chanson qui a été fait en
trois jours chrono avec donc la
mobilisation de plus de 40 artistes et
j'espère en tout cas que ça accompagné
le mouvement populaire et cette
révolution
un endroit on me dit maintenant vous
avez les voit on and on croit des
féministes algériennes ont été agressés
et insultés par d'autres manifestants
récemment leurs revendications au sein
du grand mouvement de contestation ne
font pas l'unanimité
elles sont jugées abusives
fatma oussedik sociologue et féministe
qui a participé à la plupart des marches
de madère depuis février en a fait
l'expérience
quand nous sommes sortis les premières
fois en quarts et féministe nous avons
eu droit à des menaces de mort à des
menaces d'acide des jeunes sont venus
nous ont insultés mais là larrieu qu'est
ce qu'elle demande et le créer elle
précise que les algériennes sont
majoritaires parmi les diplômés mais
qu'elle n'occupe que 17 % des emplois
elle rappelle que la situation actuelle
n'est pas nouvelle
les demandes des femmes ont toujours été
relégué au second plan dans ce pays
à chaque fois il aurait été dit que
l'heure n'était pas à leur revendication
que l'essentiel était d'abord de
transformer le politique et qu'ensuite
on tiendrait compte de leurs demandes
dans les années 50 et 60 les femmes
étaient dans les tranchées aux côtés des
hommes lors de la guerre contre la
france
on les appelait les moudjahidates au
lendemain de l'indépendance
on a célébré leur courage avant de leur
demander de retourner dans leur cuisine
[Musique]
vingt ans plus tard le gouvernement
algérien est imposé un code de la
famille une série de règlements pour
limiter les droits des femmes
rebaptisé le code de l'infamie comme le
disait les manifestantes en 1984 parmi
elles certaines des célèbres
moudjahidates comme le décrit cette
vidéo réalisée
vingt ans après l'adoption du code les
droits des femmes ont reculé avec les
années comme la société est profondément
musulmane les relations entre les hommes
et les femmes sont des relations qui ont
été construits sur une hiérarchisation
des sexes et c'est ce que reproduit le
code de la famille par exemple la femme
majeure ne peut se marier qu'avec la
présence d'un tuteur
oui allô oui bonjour l'avocate nadia aït
zaï fait partie des femmes algériennes
qui milite depuis des décennies pour
l'abolition de ce code de la famille
d'accord nous attend en vertu de ce code
les femmes divorcées perdre le droit de
garde de leurs enfants
si elle se remarie et leurs droits à
l'héritage est presque inexistant ce qui
leur interdisent d'être libre c'est la
famille c'est les frères c'est le père
donc aujourd'hui c'est ce que nous
demandons nous mêmes aux femmes c'est
qu'elles puissent s'affranchir ce qu'on
peut remarquer dans les manifestations
c'est cette liberté des femmes qui gêne
leur capacité à
aborder des questions politiques à dire
je suis citoyenne et je veux ma place
ces salades dont on a peur les
féministes algériennes engagé de longue
date compte aujourd'hui sur les jeunes
faire avancer les droits des femmes il
faut que les jeunes aillent jusqu'au
bout jusqu'au bout parce que s'ils
arrêtent hyper de tous
même si nous perdons cette fois ci il y
a des choses qui ne seront plus comme
avant ce pour aucun algérien ni aucune
algérienne nous avons reconquis la rue
et aujourd'hui on peut dire du mal ou du
bien du féminisme algeria dont on
prononce bien son
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est mon pays qui m'appelle
j'invite même les hommes à soutenir
cette revendication qui est qui est
essentiel dans l'établissement du gerry
nouvelle qui ne fait pas de différence
entre ses enfants
tout simplement
[Musique]